a todos
ele está no modo na nossa memória dessa
forma muito viva os acontecimentos a
sexta feira 3 de novembro e por isso
ainda não está toda contada também se
passou mas acho que é um facto que
também tem pra todos nós
estou e acho que uma nova batalha basear
muito da sua organização nos planos da
tecnologia muito forte embora mesmo na
internet ou mesmo mais prestigiada
publicação desta forma se o noticiado
uma informação não confirmada a noticiar
que os motoristas utilizaram uma consola
de jogos para comunicar entre si mas do
outro lado vamos apresentar no caso a
exemplo também muito concentrada nas
nossas memórias que corria curiosa 2050
- o governo mesma cidade por eles já
estarem 2015 todos os mandantes dos
ataques ao certo o dia todo e aí já
temos mais informação pública que pode
ser divulgado
a verdade é que não há outras dúvidas
que os terroristas planeavam prepararam
organizaram e escutaram executaram os
segmentos envolvidos através da
tecnologia particularmente através da
internet
não há portanto dúvidas problemas
afirmar que a internet nesses casos os
200 metros serviu para propagar o mal e
para o quarto ajudar infelizmente a
matar vem das vendas segundo set mas
também sabemos por exemplo o mesmo
exemplo você arrebentou
já temos informação sobre isso e até que
um dia pro outro lado serviu para
capturar e os mesmos motores das novas
coisas importantes para os portugueses
para nos ajudar a proteger a todos em
quantidade ou exemplo o grupo criou seis
meses o nosso trabalho ele cansou foi
completada com os destaques minutos aos
necessitados foi conectada na sua sede
em seattle estados unidos disseram na
altura 5 e 47 também é hora local
as autoridades vetaram 10 2 a francesa
segundo a polícia francesa prende
informação informações sobre dois
olhares por juristas envolvidos nesta
tarde foi de 55 minutos em apenas 45
minutos não só vamos analisar a união
lhe dar o exemplo como funciona essa
informação sobre como também mais em
quem menos 12 resistores emitiu hoje um
novo ano passado poucas horas com alguns
cobraram passar poucas horas observando
localizado e capturado estava na altura
de fuga alguns francês
portanto aqui a tecnologia funciona ou
felizmente a contagem
a tecnologia foi uma importante e
imprescindível para nos ajudar a todos
enquanto cidadãos queremos flores em
princípios constitucional acidental
ajudou a capturar o motorista a
tecnologia ajudou uma organização cívica
joão que eu dei até emocionante até os
níveis prometeu juntar tantas e tantas
voltas através das redes sociais no
mundo inteiro como alto do judiciário
que possui colégio para podermos dar
resposta efetiva à estavam a tentar
comprar a unidade de santo é para nós um
valor absolutamente essencial das nossas
nas nossas sociedades e prometeu por
exemplo também foram igualmente com
kelly quem todos os vídeos no domingo
seguinte à sociedade é maior
manifestação ocorrida naquela cidade
desde que a mesma se libertou logo
passou nas em 1954 quando o jornal o
golo aos 20 ou ausência mesmo tempo
passar
foram 22 milhões de pessoas que estavam
nas ruas países a dar uma resposta em
pectina contra quem estava a tentar
contra os nossos nosso valoroso
importante uma proposta já que falou na
teoria do futebol se apresentar com a
internet com tecnologia aqui algumas das
nossas vidas à internet vão servir para
o banho
a internet possa vir pro mal mas há
outros problemas silva entrou com
internet
fizemos nesse caso ameaça terrorista
continua com certeza que estamos nos
olhamos para esta jornada o uso
e gostamos e queremos que as nossas
polícias as nossas autoridades
cuidar da nossa segurança vigia os
espanhóis do controlo em atividade
os dois potenciais terroristas controlem
as suas correspondências controlo dos
seus movimentos no fundo pra mim não é
verdade mas popular nós também estamos
indo bem e vai
estamos com um empate que não se meter
nas nossas vidas e não salvaguarda a
nossa privacidade exemplo pensamos
quando cremos que quando cremos são
princípios base mas com a convivência
das nossas sociedades
mas há outra maneira de escrever
apresentar porque queria partilhar
convosco para fazermos todos têm a ver
com princípios sobre as nacionais
nós não gostamos porque sabemos que se
está inclinada ordem mundial e assim que
se constrói no passo que ele mandou na
escala global
nós gostamos que se espantem estreias
nacionais
não queremos que vai nos passar no nosso
país por exemplo portugal seja formar
platéia o lar ou seja através da
assembléia faz os pais professores
nacionais é muito tempo no mesmo bairro
quando o meu ponto ao mesmo tempo na
internet
temos um potencial na grife que estamos
plantando as fronteiras que o planeta é
do nosso amigo da forma como quer
experimentar uma pouco andré que falou
possa divulgar as suas preferências
as causas do mal como pequena empresa
por exemplo do dólar possa vender o seu
produto méxico austrália o canadá para
glória muito interessantes à distância
de um clique
e estes são factos grandes goleiros e eu
diria que são os maiores problemas que
nós temos hoje a nossa vida enquanto
come nada quando será o mundo tornou
necessário e que talvez falar para
perguntarmos após provas a primeira
pergunta os desafios quiserem inscrever
sar é perguntar mas todos podemos o som
da banda consciência pesada
será que estamos alertados para os
problemas só conselhos parado para
pensar sobre os problemas será que
estamos a discutir a geladeira fighters
ou deus olhe por exemplo o pense um
pouco na nossa chamada agenda mediática
mais uma quantidade de horas e horas e
horas depois a televisão e cinema tanta
coisa
tanta coisa que diga tantas vezes tanta
coisa tão mesquinha
estamos a passar por terem tomado o
vestibular teve neste momento e vou
tentar porque é mais a mesma origem da
internet
numa primeira fase já que foi a prova da
motivação limitados mas numa primeira
fase foi essencialmente físico no mundo
pra ela um conjunto nantes origem
essencialmente acadêmica quanto em
outras áreas um problema de inscrições o
livro sem custo de utilizar essa regra e
várias no mundo não existe mais hoje é
muito diferente porque nem todos os anos
numa nova lógica nós somos muitas vezes
a altura dos olhos da cor do cabelo por
telemóvel onde eu estive por onde
passarem quais são os meus gostos
ele credita hoje tem muito mais peso nas
nossas vidas do que aquilo que é
determinado tradicional que hoje em dia
2.3 mil milhões de pessoas no mundo
utilizam a internet de forma irregular
em área 46% da população mundial do
salto com vara nos próximos anos é
brutal do mais o número
90% em 90% dos dados que circulam hoje
não haver funcionários nos dois últimos
anos pois é um player implementar um
desculpa 21 vai acontecer nos próximos
cinco anos para 62 anos 34 anos como
espalhar gene que aumenta as nossas
vidas vai continuar a mudar as nossas
vidas
durante este tempo que eu confio nepal
por desenvolvendo 15 minutos de partida
inteira
durante o tempo que estou a cerca de 50
milhões de novos ou se no facebook seria
obrigado a mais de 4500 horas de vídeo
em novos filhos a serem publicados no
youtube conta que temos com o lugar
temos nos saído como pensavam os novos
tempos em que a internet não tem o mesmo
impacto poder que têm nas nossas vidas e
talvez aí pau e vale a pena para o sul
para pensar é algo tem tanto poder tem
tanto impacto na nossa vida não vale a
pena também pensarmos em controlar quem
domina é influencia
eu acho que nós não temos que torcer pra
pensar em si é um problema global mas há
um problema muito claro nacional de
câncer a portuguesa
esse é o desafio que os dois sempre
perguntar se portar nas nossas
consciências
vamos começar a pensar nisso vamos
pensar e olhar para isso observou
acreditamos ainda crescia seis
sociedades em que a participação dos
cidadãos neste grande dourados quando
vemos problema em especial quando ele os
problemas da internet aumente na foi o
crescimento da mãe digamos assim da
internet é esta que está esse é o meu
candidato independente sediada na
califórnia
apesar de entender que tal fim do dia eu
sou pra mim o departamento de comércio
do governo os estados unidos da américa
tendo tanto ler tanta influência do mal
dois anos nas mãos nada daquilo que é
brincando
está nas mãos de um homem só nos resta
dúvida
portugal encontra em actividade em
particular o governo em particular com
isso você deve ter particular do
contrário não temos nenhuma razão para
achar essa imprensa não está hoje a
sessão regular o problema é que esta é
uma questão que deve ser colocada forma
abstrata
nós hoje temos um presidente mas nós não
sabemos o que vai precisar se trata de
nós temos de nos levantar no mundo pulou
e os seus computadores não funcionavam
os seus filmes crédito possam aceder aos
dados da agência francesa que faça
multinacionais tecnológicas na china
o time de programação
lembro nada publicamente defendeu que
tenha de haver regras que proibissem a
encriptação proparco estourados prestar
vamos jogar com algumas bolsas
internacionais chama de atores não está
por exemplo a sua carreira mas não são
iguais
hoje em dia com 5 milhões de dólares é
possível criar condições para ataques
massivos contra infraestruturas
nacionais críticas em diferentes países
5 milhões de dólares não é nada escreveu
após o novo mundo muito perigoso e por
isso a mensagem que eles querem deixar a
criança no mundo
aos pulos pouco transparentes em facas
mesmas são lutas e o céu parece muito
pouco em nós temos um mapa e temos 12 a
21 01 2011 deixar passar
tivemos no mundo têm outro lado
terminado entre as nossas vidas são
controladas iluminadas por entidades
conselhos por indivíduos não conhecemos
os quais não podemos ter um bom time do
returno
por isso marcos vê que eu posso é uma
oportunidade que as ondas podem nos
emblemas também podem ser conciliador as
grandes rasgos tentando expandir nossa
vida nós temos matuto de fred para os
problemas em breve ser ativamente
significa menos intervenientes
condicionando as regras percebendo qual
o museu lançada na internet
salvaguardando o princípio e vamos
fazê-lo individual - as forças e temos
uma intervenção cívica que possa ir pôr
em causa as pessoas idosas tradicionais
mas encontramos essas novas causas
também o primeiro dos cidadãos e abriria
três álbuns
vamos fazer uma abordagem do princípio
da transparência
nós queremos uma internet com velhos
sabemos que ela tem que ter regras e
essas regras está a evitar e também que
vai controlar essas mesmas técnicas e
principalmente oferecendo a liminar não
mata a internet enquanto espaço de
criação enquanto espaço da organização
de novas idéias
enquanto faz na televisão e novas
culturas e de inspiração de saber e
conhecimento e cultura como forma eu
acho que ganhei a internet porque está
em causa a vender é muito mais
importante do que ter que obter os
problemas políticos porque às vezes nós
temos tanto os
ninguém que nós tanto nos concentrar
antes estas possam condicionar o nosso
futuro próximo o futuro dos nossos
filhos
nós temos uma internet de todos na
internet também ela pode ser uma tática
de produção de aço negado em igualdade
de pontos de aproximação entre as
pessoas e dessa maneira podemos todos
entendendo melhor sobre a dupla